well good evening welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensored live from London
sounds very difficult to be young in
today's world barely a day passes
without stories of profound woe amongst
our youth kids mental health is in
crisis we're told anxiety and depression
rampant among children there's even a
child anxiety epidemic right here in the
UK apparently it all sounds very
alarming it's also a bit confusing
because generally speaking the world is
getting more prosperous less poor safer
there are fewer Wars people are living
longer and healthier
it should be that young people feel
quite happy actually now that we've come
through the pandemic they should be but
they're not and social media probably
has a lot to do with that an entire
Digital World of vipers exists where
self-esteem can be measured directly in
lights even I would worry about that if
I wasn't well so well liked but perhaps
there's a bigger problem here and it's
us we ghastly adults at some point
decided we should teach children to be
mortally offended by everyone and
utterly terrified of everything and that
they could win it everything
never lose
fresh from ransack enrolled dials
legendary children's story so-called
sensitivity readers God that phrase just
fills my skin with horror isn't it yours
it might you just literally sensitivity
readers I've now said about canceling
you guessed it this
[Music]
what are you doing in my pea soup
I used to love the back street kids and
the those mischievous little
Rogues in Britain's best love comic book
they were always problematic it's why I
like them I like them being problematic
they've entertained children for 67
years without complaint you know what
kids can be problematic I've had four of
them the Consultants from inclusive
Minds the very same people who censor
Roald Dahl's books have quietly decided
there needs to be some changes of course
I do the B now now takes professional
advice from this Committee of fun police
which has helped to Rebrand its
characters and vet its back catalog
spotty it was called spotty because he's
spotty is now known as Scotty still got
spots you just can't say it and fatty it
was called fatty because he's fatty is
now known as Freddy even though he's
still fat we just can't call him that
the kids have been joined by five new
pupils getting harsher Mahira and
mandira in order to be more inclusive
mandira's featured in storylines about
mental health to apparently highlight
the anxieties facing children perhaps I
should do one about mandira being warned
that her friend fatty is offensive this
is from the same set of geniuses you
changed Cloud men to Cloud people in
James and the Giant Peach and decided
the black tractors in Fantastic Mr Fox
could not be described as black because
it was potentially racist to other
tractors presumably now there are two
points here the first is about
censorship if we continue to rewrite
every work of fiction based on today's
sensibilities you have to keep doing it
every 10 years until you're left with a
sanitized slab of nonsense that Bears
Zero resemblance to the original
the context of when something was
written as part of what makes it
informative and interesting the second
point is this we have a lot less about
child anxiety when fatty and spotty were
on the loose
because they were considered to be funny
then it was a joke it's a cartoon
if we genuinely want our kids to feel
happier and US anxious maybe we should
stop teaching them constantly that the
entire world is out to get them show
them how to be less offended by
absolutely everything stop allowing them
to all get a prize in everything they
compete in at school so they all think
that they're winners when sometimes
they're not because none of that is a
proper preparation for the real world
the one that in Barbie land is such a
shock to Margot Robbie when she gets to
it the real world I'm afraid is Watson
all it can be tough out there
so why don't we prepare kids
for how to handle it rather than cover
them and cut more well I'm joined Now by
broadcaster former brexit MEP Alex
Phillips talk to the contributor and
lawyer Paula Ron Adrian a political
journalist Ava Santina all right
um Alex
I I brought up four kids
uh I'm not perfect by any means
something nearly perfect does a father
probably
um but
desanitizing of everything this over
protection there's wrapping in Cotton
wool there's nobody can lose nobody can
be called any funny names in cartoons
blah blah blah it's the a is exhausting
and B all it seems to be doing is
increasing the amount of anxiety in kids
all the figures show The Situation's
getting worse not better I would argue
this strategy hasn't worked it's had the
opposite effect yeah it's utter Madness
I mean what we seem to be doing as a
society now is making our kids into
little hypochondriacs to worry about
everything to police their own language
at the time they should be learning how
to develop their communication skills to
see everything through the prism of race
to see everything through the prism of
gender and then at the same time the
things perhaps we should protect them
from adults fetish pornography we're
we're foisting upon them at an alarming
rate and I don't understand what
children are supposed to be anymore are
they supposed to engage with this Adult
World of critical race Theory and
extreme adult content 100 genders yeah
there is no more innocence safeguarding
has gone out the window all right Paula
we've discussed a lot of these issues
all right and I get that some kids are
anxious I've met quite a few kids who
have a lot of anxiety problems I think a
lot of it is social media driven I think
a lot of it is dopamine driven that
they're exposed through social media to
a constant barrage of imagery from Wars
and other things which we simply would
never see when I was a kid so that
cannot be overlooked is constant sensory
overload impacting negatively and yet
all the statistics will show young
people if they calmly explained there's
never been a better time to be alive
actually but the statistics will also
tell you peers about the suicide rate
amongst children about how their mental
health is suffering about how children
are being bullied both personally and
online in the social World social media
world and so when we look at the bino
what surprised me about this story is
that we weren't applauding what the bino
were doing we weren't you know saying we
weren't championing what they were doing
which is to stop children from calling
each other names because that's not
appropriate what do you think he's going
to stop because the Beano stops using
names I mean come on but well yes I do
actually because it's teaching children
that it's not appropriate and you call
somebody by their name which is Frank
John pauler or Alex you don't call them
spotty you don't call them you
don't call them fatty you call them by
their name and so what you are doing by
but what The Beano is doing is
acknowledging that it's anachronistic in
its style and that it shouldn't be that
it should be taking responsibility for
providing a positive message for
children stop being mean children yeah
but the trouble is life is tough Ava
life is very mean you know I always
remind people of the Rocky Balboa speech
to his son who's a spoiled entitled brat
and the sixth movie and eventually Rocky
loses it with him in the street and says
life is hard it will beat you down right
and the challenge of succeeding in life
is how many times you can get back up
and keep moving forward it's not how
hard you can punch it's about how hard
you can get punched and keep going we
know this and I my argument is I think
we're just not preparing kids properly
for the real world and and trying to
create this kind of Barbie style Utopia
where no one's mean no one uses mean
words all that kind of thing means you
basically have to airbrush now every
work of literature going back in history
because it was all full of mean stuff
yeah I think it was it was from Roald
Dahl to the B note they're all getting
censored right I don't get it I don't
get any of it works I think it's quite
obvious that parents probably don't want
to sit down in 2023 and read a bedtime
story to their child about you know
fatty and spotty I think it's probably I
do hang on I think it's probably I do
forces that have dictated it and you
love the free market and I think they've
probably looked at it and gone do you
know what bino not really being consumed
anymore why don't we try to get this you
know somehow purchased and back in
schools back at bedtime and that's this
is how they've responded let me throw
this back at you my daughter kills she's
11. she calls me fancy all the time
right and does this to me all the time
good it makes me go to the gym it's
another this morning I was actually very
very different I was actually Barbie
pressing this morning to to uh female
trainers I mean this is how I how I flow
but the point is I'm not offended when
she does that I think it's funny right
it used to be you could laugh at stuff
like that but what we're now in we're
now in a world where Cosmopolitan
magazine one of the most influential
magazines for young women in this
country but it's a 305 pound model model
on the front cover and doesn't mention
anywhere in the text it either on the
cover or inside that this is more bitly
obese and very dangerous okay it said we
celebrate being incredibly fat but if
you dare to use the word fatty in The
Beano about a fictitious character all
hell breaks loose the sensitivity
beliefs get called in it all has to be
changed explain to me how that is good
for society or good for the well-being
of young women who think that being 305
pounds when you're five foot two is a
great thing thing to be is body positive
okay because no one's got the gumption
to go sorry you are morbidly obese
you're gonna die and by the way if you
all want to be this fat you're all going
to die too but then we should have done
that for the models who were 80 pounds
and six foot tall who were on magazines
for 20 years and gave you know the whole
world eating I said the same thing about
the size zero campaign there was never
any warning on there of how women
achieved that body frame no one ever
talks about the smoking never no one
ever talked about the drug taking or the
excessive dieting none of that ever
appeared in a magazine and because I
guarantee your daughter when she calls
you fatty and you have that lovely
little inside Journey
but when you have a good joke about it
and you're having you know this nice
lovely moment I guarantee you didn't
teach her that word that's probably
something she's picked up and now you
enjoy and you have a nice life
she's teaching that because actually
kids do that kind of thing they're kids
right they're not going to stop because
the B nose changes everyone's name you
taught her that word wouldn't it if you
were at bedtime and you taught her that
word from the be no book that would be a
bit
I've tried to teach my all my kids just
don't worry about you know my mother
always told me you know we talk about
the patriarchy I lived in a matriarchy
with these wonderfully strong women in
my family my grandmother my mother my
sister my daughter's inheriting the same
thing and it's just that sticks and
stones will break your bones not words
will never hurt you come on you're very
much say never mind Sticks and Stones
words are far worse they're not they're
literally not cheers and you know that
that's not true I don't know it's true I
think that's a really dangerous Theory
to push I know that words hurt we know
that because our law recognizes that
fact that people are often mistreated
with words and that it can impact on
their lives we know that bullying which
doesn't have to include physical attacks
when we're talking about a verbal
assault on somebody can often have the
same threatening and intimidating effect
as it could if you were physically
assorted I know but my point is if you
say I know well then if you say you know
them we need to acknowledge is watching
this you think it's appropriate to stand
over a partner and Shout abuse at them
in their face or to even worship or to
even whisper it in there no there's any
viewers because my viewers are not those
sort of people uh let's oh absolutely I
would hope I'd hope that they're not
have a Discerning audience
um
recognizes that abuse can be verbal as
well you're never going to persuade me
that verbal uh mockery and stupid
phrases is ever going to come close to
physical violence or maybe Meghan Markle
might be able to do that Michael dishes
it out like everyone I've ever seen in
my life she thinks it's finally called
the royal family a bunch of horrible
racist scumbags and make hundreds of
millions of dollars you never complain
when she does that but or you only can
play any people say how disgusting you
say that that is not appropriate and
that's exactly the example that I wanted
you to no you're missing my point
completely appropriate language
people to be kind all right let's teach
people nice kind what about teaching
people to just State the bleeding
obvious